war sehr lecker von
firefall ich feiere das wollte und dazu
jetzt ein gutes bett schicken und dann
so richtig so dippel in diesen rest soße
oder auch pur essen sowie knoblauch ist
feierlich
[Musik]
hallo zusammen ich lese heute ein buch
und zwar mein kochbuch ich habe mir
gedacht ich mache aus dem orientalischen
kochbuch knoblauch nahen also indisches
nahm ich sage auch immer gerne nahmen
brot aber das wäre doppelt gemoppelt
verändern heißt er braucht auf jeden
fall es ist sehr sehr lecker es gibt
sehr schnell zeigt solche normal wenn er
sehr stolz drauf die fotos haben wir
alles selber gemacht also haben sagt
sich geschossen und ich angerichtet und
ja auf jeden fall lege ich jetzt direkt
los ich würde sagen ich benutze zwar die
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt eure hand
nehmen quatsch benutzt wenn ihr die
küche nicht benutzt eure hände weil ich
bin heute einfach zu faul aber es geht
auch ganz gut mit den händen handgeräten
sitz nicht unbedingt sein es gibt ja
jetzt direkt mal mehr ein ganz neues war
ich schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben und nimm die infobox ihr
könnt das weizenmehl übrigens auch
austauschen durch dinkelmehl typ 630
dass es in dem fall gar kein problem
dann habe ich hier salz und zucker eier
zucker gehört auch dazu dass richtigen
geschmack schön ab und als patrick
mittel brauchen wir achtung trockenhefe
und backpulver ist eine ungewöhnliche
kombi vertraut mir macht es einfach nach
schmeckt wirklich extrem flüchtig so
hier können die dich jetzt eineinhalb
teelöffel rein das ist einmal
trockenhefe backpulver nur noch einen
halben teelöffel
zwar kann man rein das ganze jetzt ganz
grob verrühren und an flüssigen zutaten
brauchen wir jetzt noch lauwarme milch
und naturjoghurt ich nur 35 prozentigen
aber ihr könnt auch eine höhere stufe
nehmen und dann lasse ich das einfach zu
einem schönen teig verkneten
[Musik]
so nach ungefähr zwei bis zweieinhalb
minuten hier in der maschine ist der
teig eigentlich schon fast fertig ich
werde ihn jetzt auf der arbeitsfläche
noch mal ein bisschen geschmeidig kneten
bzw auch zu einer kugel rollen also er
darf eigentlich nur noch minimal kleben
wenn ihr märkte klebt doch noch ein
bisschen zu viel also es ist schon ein
bisschen klebriger als ich es wollte ich
wohl noch ein bisschen mehr
dann dürft ihr ein
also wenn ich mal in mühl noch dazu gebe
es in der regel aber gar nicht nötig und
dann einfach zu einer kugel rollen mit
olivenöl benetzen und dann 45 minuten
dann gehen lassen
[Musik]
die wartezeit ist rom gemacht nichts
weiter und zwar hatte ich jetzt hier
schon mal knoblauch wir könnten jetzt
auch pressen aber ich finde wenn man
ihnen bei diesem rezept akt kann man den
einfach später besser auf dem namen brot
brot brötchen kann man das einmal besser
verteilen und habe jetzt ja auch schon
petersilie fein gehackt das mache ich
einfach später um ehrlich zu sein für
die optik das habe ich auch schon
vorbereitet jetzt mache ich erstmal oder
solche hat erzählen dass ich mein indien
war bei jedem schritt wird das interieur
ich war auch schon mal in indien habe
ich ein praktikum zu praktikum das war
freiwillige arbeit darf ich kindern
indischen kindern die man so sind habe
ich englisch beigebracht und ist immer
wieder erstaunlich finde ist wie
übertrieben glücklich die waren als wir
als sie den die zahnbürste warschau
überleg mal hier nie kinder seien mit
dem putzen sind dort ist schon echt
traurig leute aber ich liebe die
indische küche und ich liebe indien und
ich sag immer zum haben sie lasst uns
doch einmal gemeinsam nach indien
fliegen aber haben sie will nicht
jetzt nehme ich mir hier den
aufgegangenen teig wenn ihr mehr zeit
haben können das übrigens auch länger
liegen lassen ich zum beispiel mit kraft
was dazwischen und ich glaube der stand
jetzt über eine stunde das ist gar kein
problem aber jetzt nicht in sechs sieben
stunden lang stehen lassen weil dann
fängt er an zu mieten wenn ihr das in
ihrem vortrag vorbereiten möchte kann ja
auch sein vorplanungen dann könnt ihr
das im kühlschrank gehen lassen das ist
dann die kalte führung somit wird er
einmal in sechs gleich große teile
geschnitten in meine hälfte
zwei teilchen dann kriegen wir sechs
namen ich sage man laden drohte in 1 46
namen brote raus sechs brot brot so die
brote dann einfach mit den fingern oval
formen sie dürfen auch ruhig noch so
einen halben zentimeter dick sein also
es werden ja auch recht flott wie gebote
und dann geben wir den fein gehackten
knoblauch einfach oben drauf ich bin wer
knoblauch gibt kein zuviel also danach
solltet ihr euch nicht mehr mit jemandem
treffen und dann kommen
schwarzkümmel samen und sesam noch unter
und so bereitet ihr dann alle vor und
die vorgehensweise gleich beim ausparken
ist super interessant denn wir werden
das ganze das kann ich euch jetzt schon
mal zeigen eigentlich passt nummer drei
in meine fahne ich zeige es euch jetzt
mal anhand dieser beiden die schon
vorbereitet habe ich habe jetzt hier den
herz schon mal eingeschaltet und habe
stufe sieben von neun genommen
vielleicht hilft ja also schon mal auf
temperatur gebracht und dann kommen die
brote jetzt einfach rein und werden von
unten schon mal gebräunt und falls ihr
das problem habe das jetzt der teig auf
der arbeitsfläche klebt dann dürft ihr
da so ein bisschen mehl noch dazu tun
aber mir ist das gar kein problem
[Musik]
wenn jetzt eine gut beschichtete von
habt dann dürften euch die neuen boote
auch nicht anpacken und das ganze
braucht dann wirklich nur eine minute
vielleicht eineinhalb bis unten so ein
bisschen gebräunt ist jetzt glaube ich
gerade in der kamera gesehen ich kann es
auch nochmal anheben das sieht man
besser also so muss es aussehen und dann
kommen sie auch schon aufs backblech ich
nehme da mein gelocktes backblech dann
kann das auch noch mal richtig schön
zirkulieren und von unten auch noch
schön knackig wenn ziel ist es ja dass
das außen schön knusprig sind ganz feine
kruste bekommt aber innen schön flüssig
bleibt so backofen ist auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 220 grad und hitze hat
kann sich ausschalten und jetzt brauchen
sie wirklich nur fünf minuten also sie
dürfen nun ganz leicht hel goldbraun
werden und dann zeige ich euch den
letzten finalen schritt
[Musik]
so sie sind schon fast fertig jetzt
kommt noch ein entscheidendes detail ihr
wisst ja butter ist geschmacksträger
dieses rezept könnt ihr aber auch
komplett vegan machen im endeffekt
einfach nur den joghurt austauschen eine
vegane jungen alternative verwenden und
hier statt der butter könnt ihr
margarine oder halt vegane butter
verwenden ansonsten ist daher nichts
tierisches drehen jetzt hier nochmal
schön mit der zerlassenen butter
bestreichen und wie gesagt mache ich
dann auch einfach petersilie drauf fürs
auge
geschmacklich tut sich da wirklich nicht
viel und ansonsten lassen wir uns das
jetzt noch schön warm schmecken
[Musik]
so das ist das original und das ist nach
gemacht 21.12
genau aber hier muss man sagen weil
kocht mich an bearbeitungen die bilder
noch hinsichtlich farbe etc aber das ist
schon echt
super aus
ja ich muss sagen dass ich das jetzt so
lange viele fotos und entziehen geboten
bekommen aber das ist so richtig dieses
pfiffige innen und außen sondern
vielleicht feine kruste
wir bisher
sehen vor das motiv feier erfolg feiert
das soll das ist einfach nur 34 jahren
gemacht so ausgeflippt was macht das
erstmals jetzt machte der haben sie sich
ausgedacht beschichtet und dazu jetzt
ein gutes bett schicken oder ein mango
schicken beide rezepte gibt's schon auf
einem kanal kann ich euch gerne mal in
die infobox verlinken und dann so
richtig so dippel nin diese restlos oder
auch pur essen ein dass er so viel
knoblauch ist feiere ich also
es war draußen sollen der cristiano ist
hat der job aktiv
wir sagen ich muss einfach in berlin
beim in labor wir haben so geschwärmt es
war sooo lecker aber da gab sich diese
marotte da gab er dieses ballon brot
sollte ich auch vielleicht mal machen
oder welche boote soll ich noch machen
schreibt es jetzt meine kommentare
wenige der dann aus der weg wird liegt
auch ganz lieben gruß von mir
ja mein archiv arabische spezialität wir
haben ja auch sagt dafür betriebsschluss
palästina gekommen okay ich merke schon
wir haben richtig viele ideen zu kommen
videos also ich mache jetzt wirklich
noch ein leckeres indisches mittagessen
dazu mit seinen erwärmung ist wirklich
auch
gleich genießen kennt man sonst haben
wir so noch was zu sagen wollte
cheftrainer karlheinz
nachmachen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal
[Musik]